hey guys this is dennis the founder of
thick hair and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of the walking
dead season 4 episode 5 internment yes
another episode this is the thing that
the walking in at that I think it's kind
of like how lost was it's a victim of
its own success yes lost they didn't
know that it was going to be such a big
hit and then it was and they said okay
well we got to keep the show on as long
as possible so they kind of drag things
out and especially in season two in the
first half of season three of lost it
just they didn't know what to do with it
so they couldn't move the storyline
further and I just had a lot of these
like side episodes so I feel like
walking dead they didn't know is gonna
be such a big success it is and now they
just trying to drag everything out like
for the first i'd say like 45 minutes of
this episode nothing really happened I
mean towards the end we got to see a lot
of zombie killing right and you know
some some story stuff did come up toward
an end but for a good 45 minutes doesn't
happen not much before Bursar's jumping
on us so we say nothing happening a lot
of people think that we Dennis and I
mean action yeah like well this goes
wasn't a big fight scene this meeting
happen no like dennis is favorite show
and talks and I assume still is
boardwalk empire mine is mad men and if
any of you who watch work Empire or
madam and those are not action kilim
shoot-'em-up driven kind of shows I'm
final people just talking for an hour
straight yeah I can handle that but when
it's just like you can't just show me
people sick and die even if it's um you
know Steven Yeun who you i really like
as Glenn Glenn who's just saying their
guy don't want him to die but it's like
yeah it's using the same things over I
mean for half the episode they're fixing
the fence for the other half they got
people sick and then the end the
governor shows up like old that debt
that makes it all worth of them like no
actually it doesn't it means i watched
45 minutes of something that really
wasn't that great and then you know be
give me the governor thing that's like
the only thing i don't know i just it's
frustrating the show start your
frustration well cuz they're dragging
things out again i think they don't
never made that jump to 16 episodes they
should have stayed at twelve to thirteen
episodes i think a season they're taking
about like 2015 20 minutes of story and
then make
No the whole episode I mean we got you
know a little bit story at the end with
with Daryl coming back and Tyrese and we
know that eventually he's gonna Darryl's
gonna have to talk to Rick about Carol I
was looking for today it never happened
the same in it they're saving it it's
like stop say let's just get to the meat
let's get to it and just like they saved
the govern now the governor's here yeah
I mean I guess witless isn't first
started we even called us out and I'm
sure as many of you did in the comment
section with a premiere we know all
these new characters gonna come gonna
get killed off any yeah and other does
that's it there is getting killed off
well you don't feel anything for him and
so they put the montage with acoustic at
the music and it's like much was to feel
something for the people die like I
don't I don't know them I don't know
these new people yeah only Glenn was the
one that was a gold yeah I don't want to
die yeah you know the only one that we
actually felt a connection to but then
the other ones like the doctor like
whoever else they were saving we're just
like oh who cares yeah it's just I don't
know they're trying to get these really
deep drama these moments but I don't
like you she said like they haven't
earned those now with these new
characters anyway with Glenn sure but
with these new characters I don't really
care about what happens to him yeah and
then and yeah then it's kind of cool
saying that Rick and his son Carl bonded
over a shooting me shooting machine and
zombies I don't know how it's the
equivalent of a playing catch with your
dad cuz they have no idea though I don't
know how a young kid like Carl could
like suddenly be so adept at its
shooting them Rambo yeah and ramble like
that yeah just move for houses the clip
to dad take that do that as you'll do as
one does um yeah like I really want to
get into this season I want to like it
but it's like I just I can't just seeing
people sick for 40 minutes doesn't do
anything for me it's like I get it it's
robert rises the show needs to move on
to something else it needs it really
need something i may be the governor
will bring that i helped me i like to
david moore see he's a good actor I hope
this episode ends that there is this end
to the flu I don't want to see any more
of that hopefully now they brought the
medicine back
gradually gets better and they were over
this and then let's move on to this
governor whatever the hell the
governor's gonna do cuz that could be
interesting i don't know i mean i think
they should have killed them off of the
lassies not because I don't like david
morrissey i think is they could just
moved on to something different but if
he's back it could help it could be some
bubbly yeah and then i'm sure we'll see
Carol at some point we'll find out yeah
yeah maybe Darrell will go looking for
her and then Darrell you know who's one
of the major guys my place having him
gone it will be like kind of like a
weakness that they have but yeah as of
right now I just feel like I just think
they're just stretch knit thin yeah
they're stretching it then and and I
want to see more this show has the
pieces to be a great show yeah you got a
good cat it's you know it's got you know
good it does have a good story at time
yeah it doesn't like yeah yeah um you
know you mean last season with with the
prison and Woodbury and you know we had
that interesting dynamic right now we're
just not having that much of it yeah it
just seems like it's struggling my face
little pieces here and there like okay
this parts interesting this parts
interesting but as a whole we're not
getting too much yeah I fell like this
whole episode was just a tease until
like oh here's a governor by the way
it's like okay that's interesting I
guess I'll hold me til next week we'll
see them alright guys so what do you
guys think I mean are you guys enjoying
this still is it you know are you
looking forward to every next the
walking dead episode or are you like us
where it's like yeah they have nuggets
of good stuff yeah but they're taking a
long way around to get to it and all
right you know are you sick of the
zombie flu yet cuz I think I hopefully
is gone hopefully this life you can post
your comments below on the website think
CARICOM or on our YouTube channel that's
think you're a pro make sure you
subscribe to that we're gonna check us
out on Twitter it's been talked with
Dennis or any of us here it's at think
hero i'm at griffin de and we have a
Facebook page that's a facebook.com
slash think Carol fans make sure you
like that page you know tweet and share
our video on Facebook and Twitter and
stuff like that
you